on revient montréal encore une histoire
vous allez voir de places de
stationnement sur le plateau mont royal
en fait c'est une bataille rangée entre
le maire ferrandez de l'arrondissement
du plateau et le maire de la ville
centre
denis coderre françois cormier ça
concerne le début de l'histoire c'est un
aménagement quel maire ferrandez voulait
faire autour d'une piste cyclable sur la
rue brébeuf je crois donc de d'enlever
des places de stationnement là monsieur
coderre a dit neil hannon ça marche pas
je vous corrige on peut pas triste parce
que c'est un voleur n'était pas de la
responsabilité de luc ferrandez en fait
ce sont des travaux qui était de la
responsabilité de la ville centre est
étrangement c'est denis coderre qui
s'est rendu compte que les travaux dont
il avait la responsabilité n'était
peut-être pas les meilleurs en tout cas
dans son esprit je vous montre de tout
de suite de quoi il s'agit en fait on
est sûr brébeuf au coin de lauriers il
ya une piste cyclable voyez donc le
terre plein qui est installée au tout
début de la rue ce qu'on voulait faire
c'est pour suivre ce terre-plein là tout
au long de la rue brébeuf vous aurez
compris avec les voitures qui sont
stationnés au loin que si on avait fait
ça sur cette russie ça enlevait des
places de stationnement le maire coderre
ne veut absolument pas faire ça parce
que dans ce quartier patrice c'est ici
qu'il ya eu une pétition déposée on en a
parlé au cours des dernières semaines
concernant des vignettes de
stationnement qui avaient été imposées
aux résidents ça n'avait pas fait la
sphère de plusieurs commerçants donc le
maire on va se le dire il ya vu une
opportunité politique de marquer le coup
a décidé donc d'interrompre les travaux
qui a été évidemment a dénoncé
aujourd'hui par l'administration de luc
ferrandez par projet montréal on peut
les écouter il y a des des citoyens qui
se sont alarmés du fait que la piste
cyclable prendrait plus espace sur la
rue brébeuf et que pour eux ça pose des
difficultés
ce qui est surprenant parce que toutes
les pistes cyclables à travers montréal
partout lorsqu'elles sont construites
près de l'espace c'est que vous avez
9600 pétitionnaires qui ont parlé de ce
petit coup de ce coin là au niveau des
résidents d'anti lauriers au niveau des
résidences au niveau des commerçants et
la baisse à leurs pets d'en face dans le
merveilleux royaume du plateau il ya une
claque l'a amené on pensait qu'on peut
toutefois ce qu'on voulait non ça marche
pas comme ça
mais françois là je reviens à la charge
d'expliquer moi bien parce que j'ai un
doute on peut pas se laisser sur
l'origine la personne qui voulait faire
ces travaux là c'était bien
l'administration centre où c'était
l'arrondissement c'était c'était la
ville centre patrice ans que contre le
fait parce que les pistes cyclables donc
son sens de responsabilité de la ville
centre alors c'était vraiment le projet
de la ville centre qui avait passé les
étapes du comité exécutif du conseil du
conseil municipal du conseil
d'agglomération qui avait été voté à
plusieurs reprises et donc ce n'était
pas un projet de l'administration
ferrandez ils l'avaient appuyé monsieur
fernandez l'avait appuyé voyez ça venir
donc les travaux et laissez-la monsieur
coderre a stoppé ses propres travaux et
effectivement et l'on sait pas quel coup
ça hors us qui aura des pénalités parce
que monsieur coderre dit que peut-être
des solutions entre autres vous le voyez
peut-être derrière moi il ya un espèce
de passage ici on pourrait peut-être
donc déplacé le passage pour piétons
dans le parc enlever le trottoir qui se
trouve derrière moi et donc élargir la
piste cyclable mais il reste que
plusieurs solutions sur la sur la table
à dessin
alors faudra voir sur des pénalités à
payer à l'entrepreneur qui devait
commencer ses travaux incessants coups
enlever la rue je vous la junte